One of the things that I think politics systematically,
underwrites and importance,
and tends to be very bad at talking about is technological change just in
general, how important it is, what is happening with it?
We functionally live in a gerontocracy where, um,
I think Nancy Pelosi's 80 Trump is 74, Joe Biden to 77.
Um, Mitch McConnell is in the upper seventies. I think he might be 77.
Like this is not the most tech forward leadership, uh,
group you could possibly imagine.
And so a lot of what is changing in technology, which is really important,
I think it gets under played.
So let's have a little bit of a conversation there. AI,
how has your thinking changed on it in the past few years compared to, you know,
two years ago or whatever it was when we talked,
do you think the landscape there has changed? Um,
do you think there are things people should know that have happened?
A lot of the things I was concerned about have now come into full
view because of the pandemic and you know,
that companies that were considering investing in AI and
robotic meatpackers and the rest of it, and a robot, aisle cleaners,
and a grocery store. Now those companies are accelerating the investments.
And the example I use is that now if you get a Domino's
pizza and a self-driving car, you're excited because you had less human contact.
Whereas before it seemed a little bit creepy, um,
same with the self checkout aisle.
And if you look at AI that there's this new release that now,
uh, can do a lot of writing and basic summaries on a level that's
indistinguishable from human journalists. You're.
Talking to you about opening the eyes, GPT three. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Open the eyes GPT.
Yeah. So if people haven't heard of this, I'm going to put in show notes.
My colleague, Kelsey Piper did a great piece on this, but it's surreal.
Let me put it that way.
W what it's able to do in terms of language processing is wild.
And two years ago, if you'd asked me, Hey,
is software going to get to this point? I would say, I would have said yes,
but then you could still argue over it. You know what I mean? Uh,
and now two years later,
it's here and you can see the commercial potential of this
technology.
One of the reasons why I was so concerned about the impact of AI on our labor
force Ezra, is that I know how many frankly,
inefficient jobs there are. And a lot of these major companies,
where if you gobble up another company and you have two different systems,
you might keep dozens,
even hundreds of folks around just to keep the systems talking to each other.
It'd be like this. There's a lot of weird stuff.
When you get into the bowels of some of these organizations. Uh,
and I knew that over time, AI could end up making a lot of those types of jobs,
less and less central, the arguments about human labor and AI,
they tend to be non-market driven and kind of romantic. It'd be like, Oh,
you know,
like you can ever replace a human who does what Ezra does or after
does, or, or whatnot. But, you know, a,
a lot of our work is more replaceable than we'd like to think.
And what's funny is if you ask Americans about this,
they will actually say a majority of other people's jobs are automateable and
subject to technological replacement.
And then if you ask them about their own job, the vast majority will say,
not my job. Uh, you know, that's just the way we're wired.
I'm fleeing to the high ground of podcasting. I mean,
they're going to come for the column this way before they come for the
podcasters. It's much, much,
much harder for AI to have a good conversation than for it to just write up a,
write up a take on the GDP report.
Anyone, anyone like us, we're already at the top of the pyramid.
You know what I mean? Like if you have a podcast with a significant audience,
you're, you're, you've already made it to a certain point. Like,
and if you think about all the folks who are coming of age right now,
like the younger versions of us who are graduating from college right now,
it's like, you know, uh,
it's w w the winner take all economy applies in many
spaces, including the ones that you and I are.
Oh, absolutely. I want to talk about something else.
A lot of the problems that I care most about solving,
they have a huge technological dimension to them. Um,
I care a lot about animal suffering, and by far the most, uh,
promising way to do something about that is plant cell-based meat,
Kellogg about climate change. And while I've had Saul Griffith on the show,
talking about how we could fix climate change without anything,
any new technology being invented,
there's just no doubt that given the level of mandate and adoption and take up
that we'll need, if we can invent some great new stuff,
it would become a lot easier. AI often gets talked about in a dystopic way,
but if we really could invent it, it could make life pretty amazing.
And one of the things that has struck me is that I don't think progressives in
general have much of a theory of technology anymore. Um,
I think that it's often talked about, and is this topic way,
there's all the frustration at the billionaires who own it,
I will often felt you sort of like oscillated between like a very scary story
about AI,
and then also like a real interest in technology as a way of solving problems.
And I'd love to just hear you reflect on that. Like, what should,
what do you think the political orientation to technology in general should be?
I love where you are on this Ezra. Like,
I think that ideally Progressive's are for progress and you
know, what is going to enable a ton of progress is technology.
And one of the fun things about, um,
my campaign was I was making some very dark arguments about the impact of
technology, which I completely believe, uh, you know,
like if you have autonomous trucks in the next, you know,
I'll extend the timeline. Cause I know you and I differ on this, but with like,
let's say like 20 years, you know,
like there'll be millions of folks who used to drive a truck for a living who,
you know, will need something else to do. So, like,
I believe all of that wholeheartedly,
but I also agree with you that if you're trying to make people smarter,
healthier, mentally healthier, uh, trying to clean up our planet, uh,
trying to feed people in a way that doesn't brutalize animals. Uh,
technology is a part of every single of those solutions in a very central
way. And the,
one of the dangerous to me about a lot of our politics now is where we're each
arguing for different brands of nostalgia. You know what I mean? Meanwhile,
time only goes in one direction, you know, it's 20, 20,
you're now out in California. I got,
I spent a lot of time there and you go to some of the folks who are working on
the future and it is wild.
Like some of the things that they're working on are very, um,
positive and inspirational. Uh, some of them are very depressing and dystopian,
um,
but they're all packaged together and we should not be a group of people or a
party that also has our heads in the sand about the
positive and negative changes that technology brings.
Like we have to be the party that is hard-nosed and realistic,
but also willing to embrace the technologies that could
lead us to something that more closely resembles utopia than this current mess
we're living. Uh, so I, I love what you just said as well. I was like, uh,
you know, I completely agree.
Like we need to be embracing these technologies at a much higher level and I'm,
I may be a part of that in this next administration, if, um, you know, uh,
if we succeed in getting Trump out of their way, uh.
Follow up on that tantalizing, I may be a part of that. Um,
is there a job you've been talking about?
Oh, so I've had just very, very general informal conversations with, uh, uh,
the bind camp about trying to take on some sort of technology facing role,
both some of the concerns that I campaigned on and trying to address them.
And one thing we haven't talked about, but I'm very passionate about that.
You will be two in a few years is the effect of social media and
technology on our kids' mental health. Uh, you know,
like right now you have massive levels of anxiety and depression among teenage
girls in particular. Um, in order to make, uh,
certain companies like Facebook richer, which, you know, is not a good look,
but our government is way behind the curve on these issues.
And I've offered my help in trying to catch us up. And there's some interest,
uh, in taking me up on that.
And so, so then to go back to this underlying question,
you said something I thought that's worth picking up on about,
you've talked to people in Silicon Valley and you go look at what they're doing.
And some of it is very utopian and some of it is very dystopian and I've had
probably some of the same conversations with even some of the same people you
have. And what always strikes me is that it's not in most
cases intrinsic to the technology, which way that plays out.
And oftentimes it is actually about the way the government and both the
rules of markets and regulations, but also to some degree,
government implementation, taxation, et cetera,
is going to interface with the technology.
That's going to decide whether it ends up being like utopian or dystopian.
And so there's sometimes seems to me to be a more obvious approach here,
which is that I would say that it should be a more central
priority, frankly,
for both parties to use the government as a research and innovation accelerant.
But then it also has to be a more central priority again,
hopefully for both parties,
for the government to have views and to care about how the
technology is rolled out, who has access to it,
and also what rules it operates under.
Yeah. That it's spot on as rhe. Uh,
and right now our government is out to lunch on most of these
technology issues and we need to change it, you know, and I agree with you,
they should be essential for both parties because the rate of change is just
getting faster and faster.
We got rid of the office of technology assessment in 1995, 25 years ago. Uh,
and we can all sense that, well, there was no more technology. Oh yeah, no,
we invented everything 95, 95.
It's embarrassing. Really. And we can all sense it,
like everyone just has this collective groan when it comes to government and
technology. And then again,
you have something like healthcare.gov where you're like, Oh no,
they tried to make a website
mean I shouldn't laugh because it was freaking terrible.
So if you were helping to modernize government on technology in a,
in a future administration, how would you think about that? Uh, where,
where would you start? What would,
what would be the kinds of things you would imagine doing.
Ramp up the United States,
digital service and empower it and you and I both know that there are hundreds,
maybe even thousands of very talented technologists
designers, coders,
who would help a government if they had a runway to do so and
felt like they could actually be empowered as opposed to going into sitting in
meetings and getting their hands tied and red tape and bureaucracy and the rest
of it. Uh, so that would be step one, you take,
what's been working and then you pour fuel on it. Um, that the,
the other thing I would be trying to do is, um, I,
I think that there should be some kind of West coast base of operation and part
of the talent enlistment move because of,
there are a lot of techies that might not want to uproot their families and head
to DC. And so you need to give them a place to reside in and land.
And then we need to have actual experts getting the guts of the social media
companies and the apps,
because each of these companies is its own thing.
Like you can't really have one size fits all. For example,
20th century antitrust rules when it comes to Facebook and Instagram and the
rest of it, though,
I do think that they should not have allowed them to acquire Instagram. Um,
but that there,
there are all of these features that are company specific that you need real
expertise to try and get to the bottom of and see if you can curb the worst of
the excesses.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.